رونالدو يقود فريق موسم الرياض وبيكي
يواصل الرد على شاكيرا واجويره يحتفل على
طريقه ميسي ورونالدينيو يحتفل بكاس السوبر
الاسباني هذه الاخبار وغيرها تتابعونها
على العربيه رياضه اهلا بكم
منح رئيس الهيئه العامه للترفيه في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه تركي ال الشيخ
النجم البرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو شاره
قياده فريق نجوم النصر والهلال قبل
المواجهه التي ستجمعهم في نادي باريس سان
جيرمان الفرنسي ضمن كاس موسم الرياضه
وتقام المباراه المنتظره في التاسعه عشر
من الشهر الجاري بحضور ميسي
بعد ما حققت اغنيه شاكيرا الجديده خارج
على ماك اكثر من 123 مليون مشاهده على
يوتيوب لكي يوصل الرد على حبيبته السابقه
ويقود هذه المره سياره رينو حيث قالت في
اغنيتها استبدلت الفيراري بتويكو كنايه
عنه استمتلها بفتاه اقل
[موسيقى]
شارك النجم الارجنتيني المعتزل اغويرو في
دوري الهواء الذي ينظمه ونجح لاعب مانشستر
سيتي السابق في تسجيلها كما احتفل على
طريقه ميسي خلال مباراه هولندا والارجنتين
في مونديال قطر
[موسيقى]
هن الان نجم البرازيلي رونالدينو فريقه
السابق برشلونه على تحقيق لقب كاس السوبر
الاسباني في الرياض معلقا نتيجه جميله
تهاني لاداره النادي وايضا لصديقه شعبي
نحن نثير على الطريق الصحيح
[موسيقى]